regional Nearline Goldline hey Stephanie
what are you doing I'm trying to
organize my objects into the appropriate
storage classes but why because if I
organize them properly I could save a
lot of money well that I know but why
are you doing them one by one but you
know you can automate this entire
process simply by using lifecycle
management rules sounds like you're
about to show me how let's jump right in
if we're talking about lifecycle
management we need to have a clear
understanding of the different prices
and features that each one of the
different classes provides so let's go
ahead and go through a high-level
overview of them first we have multi
regional storage which will provide geo
redundancy meaning that is generally
good for storing frequently and globally
access content then we have regional
storage which is great for data needing
to be kept in a single region meaning
that it's best suited for data sets that
will only be accessed from a particular
region then we also have Nearline
storage which is metaphor in frequently
accessed data here you pay a cheaper
price for storing your data but you must
also pay for retrieving it the math
works out so that if you access the data
less than once per month then you're
actually saving money by using your line
and lastly we have : the SLA is for :
are the same as near line but the price
for storing an object is even lower here
we also have a fee for retrieving the
data and in this case the math works out
so that if you access data less than
once per year you'll be saving money now
lifecycle management is an easy and
simple way to automatically move objects
from one storage class to another by
simply setting a set of rules instead of
having to do the process manually the
idea is that if you are not accessing
objects within specific time periods
there is a substantial amount of money
that you could save by taking advantage
of the different storage classes the
different rules by which you could set
these automatic policies or the
following H created before is life which
is basically just asking if you have the
latest version and whether it matches a
specific storage class let's go into the
console now and show you how easy this
is to set up so now that we're in the
console we're gonna click on the burger
menu and go to the storage section of
the console here you'll see a bucket
that I created called take five demos
and you'll see that no lifecycle
management rules have been specified if
we go into the bucket you can see a
series of objects that I added in two
different dates about three days apart
from each other on the 18th and on the
25th this month now we'll go back to the
main page and actually add some of this
lifecycle management rules and click on
none and we'll go ahead and add a rule
here we can specify the type of rule
that we want to add H created by and so
on that we described earlier we'll go
ahead and select H and we'll
find the age in this case we'll set it
to three we'll go ahead and continue and
say what this rule will do which in this
case will set the objects to : we'll go
ahead and save this rule that's another
example go ahead and add another rule
this time if any object is older than
one day it will automatically set that
object to Nearline now that we set up
these rules let's go back to our objects
within our bucket to see how they've
been classified now we sped up this
process for the video but this usually
takes about a day now you can see all of
our different objects within the bucket
and you can see that the storage class
has changed to cold line for some of
them and regionals for other now this is
a really quick demo of how you can use
lifecycle management to manage your
objects well now that my lifecycle
management is automated I can spend much
more time developing cool features and
we thought the money you're saving you
should ask for a raise you're right
well don't forget everyone to like
subscribe and share and we'd love to
hear your thoughts
what lifecycle management strategies
would you take on Google Cloud storage
comment below and if you'd like to get
in contact with us click on the link in
the description
[Music]